we've got is an artificial intelligent
platform that that learns about your
spending patterns and its ultimate aim
is to help you manage your money the
incubation lab which we've set up in
Studio B is to have you come and tell us
how you'd like your service to be
delivered so in many cases banks have
pushed product they push services at you
and then you just decide if you want
them or not this is a pull model so
instead of the old banking model in the
UK say the customer old as the hills
what do you want Howard how do I could
deliver it what products what service is
what style what hours you tell us so if
you go into Studio B all the emerging
technologies are there there's a lab for
you to access and use yourself where you
can design and innovate what you want
and in fact the original concept of be
the brand and the application we first
put out there for account opening was
designed by 10,000 customers so what are
the kind of things that you're finding
from customers what are the things that
they want from this service they want to
trust you that's the very first thing
and if you're helping to manage money
and they discovered that they got a text
as I did myself saying based on your
forecast cash flow perhaps you might not
have enough for your direct debits this
month or you might run to an overdraft
they're starting to realize that that
kind of service from a bank is very rare
and what it just did was help you avoid
a charge instead of getting hit with a
surprise overdraft charge that's a
that's a whole different trust dynamic
we have I can't believe it's a banking
CIO is in danger of going into the red
well I think I hadn't managed my own
money as they're busy managing every
else's and I I think what I had was I
was setting up the accounts and I was
doing bank transfers and switching
direct debits but I experienced it I've
talked about the design with people by
experience it for the first time and
then I have since then moved a lot of
people onto the account and explain the
product and I think that's personally
doing that with customers with friends
has helped me understand why they see it
so valuable it's about a year since
you'd emerge from National Australia
Bank you've clearly got big ambitions
for this business I mean you talk to
Royal Bank of Scotland about buying
Williams in Glynnis going to be like
five years from there well I think our
ambition is is to be very clear it is
to deliver on our promises to
shareholders in the core business so do
we need to buy anything absolutely not
the core business is a fantastic it's
not about that bank very loyal customers
powerful deep multi-generational brands
it just maybe was not run ideally from a
far away place in Australia huge
opportunity for us to improve that and
to rebuild that relationship we used to
have in history so a fantastic starting
point what we would look at is
delivering you have to when you become
independent and you become a plc deliver
what you promised simple as that
and so we said for the first couple
years absolutely that's the core
activity and will deliver double-digit
returns without acquisition now we also
said that in the event that there is a
particular opportunity that comes up in
the marketplace which is complementary
to our geography to add more capability
in the geography up north and equally
we'll be exponentially or certainly
significantly in excess of the plan over
time of the current plan if we can
achieve both those things we're
delivering more customers and where
they're living to shareholder value so
so it has to meet both of those criteria
so if there is anything out there that
we consider meets those objectives we'll
bring it to our shareholders